so many congratulations how are you
feeling tonight
feeling
so good amazing
and can't wait to
see much adventure and happy things
coming
i have to ask about your dress this is
incredible tell me a secret about the
dress
oh it's a
louis vuitton and made by nicola
and also
jules from louis vuitton yeah
how great does she look
she looks like a mermaid
how do you sit down in that
i don't know let's figure it out inside
you might have to help her yeah
yeah yeah you guys need yeah i'll try
i'll try to help you
so they can sit here
there you go bring extra guests you have
more seats so you know i have to ask
season two have you started filming yet
what can the fans expect
i'm working on it we haven't announced
it yet but we will announce it soon so
just wait
what do you want to achieve with season
two
i don't know i'm the season one was like
kind of best
in the history of like netflix so i i'm
it's like it's such a pressure for me
you know but i'll do my best to please
people who is waiting for the season too
you know he can do it yeah we all know
it we heard you got to meet up with
zendaya what was that like and could we
see you appear on euphoria
i would love to
i
uh once i visited the set of euphoria
and it was so nice to see the set
because it's been a while that i didn't
went to the set i didn't go to the set
after speed game so it was weird because
i felt so comfortable to be just sitting
and then
i'm not a team of
euphoria but i always feel more like
safe and comfortable so yeah
well could we see you appear in season
two in a flashback maybe
maybe her
the the twin sister
comes to season two
twin sister
[Laughter]
all right nominated tonight right yes
right how do you feel i'm nervous
nervous yeah what will you do if you get
up there
[Music]
i can't imagine i can't do nothing
we heard alan kim is here and he really
wants to meet you can we make that
happen
right behind alec here alan come here
alan are you excited yes
you love you love squid game
i've never watched it
okay i had to check i had to check out i
had to check
you